Now, let's take a look at
a full example of a case.
This is a head and neck
example, and the CT scans
are shown on the right.
There are a total
of 132,878 voxels.
The target, or tumor,
has 9,777 voxels.
There are five
critical structures
that we want to minimize the
dose to-- the spinal cord,
the brain, the brain
stem, the parotid glands,
and the mandible or jaw.
We're using five
beams, and each beam
is composed of
about 60 beamlets.
In total, there
are 328 beamlets.
In this example, we want
the dose to the whole tumor
to be between 70 and 77 gray.
The spinal cord dose should
be no more than 45 gray,
since significant damage to
any voxel in the spinal cord
will result in loss of function.
The brain stem dose should
be no more than 54 gray,
and the mandible dose should
be no more than 70 gray.
The average parotid gland dose
should be at most 26 gray.
This constraint is
a little different,
since the parotid gland
is a parallel structure.
Significant damage
to any one voxel
does not jeopardize function
of the entire organ.
So what is our
optimization problem now?
Again, our decisions are the
intensities of the beamlets.
Our objective is to minimize the
total dose to healthy tissue.
Our constraints are
limits on the tumor dose
and upper bounds for the spinal
cord, brain stem, and mandible.
We also have a constraint to
limit the average parotid dose
to 26 gray.
Lastly, all of our intensities,
or decision variables,
should be non-negative.
We solved this
optimization problem,
and this plot shows the results.
On the x-axis is the
dose, in gray, and on
the y-axis is the
fraction of voxels
that received that
dose or higher.
Each line corresponds to
a different structure.
We can see that for the tumor,
which is shown as the red line,
100% of the voxels get a dose
of 70 gray, and 0% of the voxels
get a dose of more than 77 gray.
This is what our
constraint specified.
While none of the
critical structures
are getting very
high doses, it looks
like the mandible, which
is shown as the blue line,
is receiving the highest
dose of the healthy organs.
In the next video, we'll
explore different solutions
and the shadow prices
of our constraints.